congratulations you baby boy right baby
boy was it exciting
because I had a little girl just like
you and then I had a little boy and I
was I was excited because I got one of
both were you I'm one of both and I I
think I'm good you're done closed yes
one one of each
um it's exciting it definitely was
you know just a different way I did
surrogacy yeah and the second time right
the second time yeah the first time I
carried on my own
um the second time I did surrogacy and
it's I mean it's amazing I wish I had
known about that this could I had
horrible pregnancies it was like
hospitalized and so yeah so I but I
didn't really even know about it or know
what it was like in my circle but it's
brilliant it's it's amazing I had
reasons why I couldn't carry myself no
me too right and yeah it's such a
blessing that we have this and I my
sister Kim had two babies through
surrogacy she had two that she carried
on her own and her last two were through
surrogacy if it wasn't for Kimberly I
definitely don't think I would have been
as you would have been aware I wouldn't
have been aware I wouldn't have known as
much I watched her go through her
journey and I'm so grateful for how open
she's always been about her journey
because yeah and not every journey is
the same mine was very different from
hers yeah I think her journey
was way more
just I think she was more maybe not
involved I don't know the term but like
it was just more comfortable for her for
me I'm such a control freak oh yeah
you'd be like what are they eating what
are they drinking what are they put in
their body a stranger I just have to
trust you and I love my surrogate she
was amazing but I'm still like I need
you sitting next to me all the time I
need to know what you're doing what are
you eating yeah so it was
um I think I would have been a little
like that too yeah had I known yeah and
a control freak I take as a compliment
so I'm not offended
because people always say control freak
but it's like or you just know what you
want in particular yeah I think that
that's fine
for other people yeah it's great for me
you know yeah I think they just need to
get over it um so wait so you you
haven't revealed your son's name yet so
is there is like a family name like a
hint like well is it like my daughter
says his name is snowy oh your daughter
it's not snowy so that's the hit I was
like were you a big Game of Thrones fan
Jon Snow I swear she just does things to
sort of like mess with me but his name
is not snowy
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
guys I'm going